this is nature at its most cruel and
weird in Australia Bren askwith has just
squirted this spider with bug spray and
released an even more hideous bug this
looks like something from a sci-fi movie
like x-files or something it's awful
what exactly is this creepy creature and
what was it doing inside the spider the
one bursting out of the spider belongs
to the nematode family it's called Amer
Mithun and it's a type of endo parasite
a parasite that lives inside another
creatures body so yes before
disgustingly bursting out of the spider
this creature was disgustingly eating
the spiders insides would gets inside
the spider when the spider either eats
the worm eggs or eats some other animal
but it's eaten with the worm eggs the
eggs then hatch inside the spider and
the worm begins to feed these parasites
don't just eat indiscriminately they eat
in a very specific order keeping the
spider alive as long as possible this
will carry on for anywhere between 7
days and 3 months and the spider starts
to show the effects of this it will
become slow and sluggish lose its
appetite and eventually near the end it
will start drinking a lot of water this
makes sense because the parasite wants
the spider to keep going to the water
because the parasites going to lay its
eggs in the water in the case of the
spider it was sprayed with bug spray so
the spider died and so the worm had to
emerge early spot is not the only
animals that suffer from these kind of
endoparasites
is a whole range of worms that are
evolved to prey on other insects
everything from preying mantises to
crickets
time for us to get a wriggle on